ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
นะคะผู้หญิงคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วัน
ศุกร์ค่ะวันนี้วันศุกร์นะคะวันที่เท่า
ไหร่คะ
วันที่ 18 ค่ะวันที่ 18 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
มีนาคมค่ะเดือนมีนาคมปีค.ศต.ยคะปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะปีพตเท่าไหร่คะปีพต 2
565 ค่ะเมื่อปีพ.ศ
2565 นะคะตอนนี้เวลา
ตึกๆเวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้เวลา
ถ้าโมง
26 นาทีค่ะ
05:26 นาทีกาดผู้หญิงเรามีนักเรียนทาง
ทั้งหมดกี่คนคะเรามีนักเรียนทั้งหมด 1  2
3  4  5  6  7  8  9  10  10 คนค่ะครู
เอ๋เอ๋เรามีนักเรียนทั้งหมด 10 คนอ่าเป็น
ผู้ชายกี่คนคะ
เป็นผู้ชาย
7 คนค่ะและนักเรียนผู้หญิงกี่คนโป้ขานัก
เรียนผู้หญิง
3 คนค่ะเพราะบวกกัน
ก็ครั้งหมด 10 คนนะคะไอ้สัตว์เล่าเรามี
ครูกี่คนคะเรามีครู 2 คนค่ะผู้หญิงกี่คน
ผู้
หญิง 2 คนค่ะครูผู้ชายมีหรือไม่มีค่ะอ่ะ
วีดีโอนี้ครูผู้ชายไม่มีค่ะไม่มี
ครูผู้หญิงผู้หญิง 2 คนนะคะๆผู้หญิงผู้
หญิงชอบอะไรคุยอิ๋งผู้หญิงหรอ
ท่อ
Shopping  Happy  1 ชอบช็อปปิ้ง
ผู้หญิงชอบไปซื้อใช่ไหมค่ะซื้อซื้อปากกา
ซื้อ
กระเป๋า
ซื้อหมูซื้อซื้อเสื้อหูอะไรคะหนูกระเป๋า
ค่ะแพร์กับปี 2
ซื้อ
ที่คัดผม
คาดผม
ซื้อแก้วหน้าเสือแก้วซื้อซื้ออะไรอีกซื้อ
ถ้าเช็ดหน้ากระเป๋าไปแล้วนี่ซื้อ
ตุ๊กตา
ถ้าซื้อก็ต้องมีอะไรคะเงินค่ะค่ะมีเงินนะ
คะอะคู๋มีกระเป๋าแล้วเปิดกระเป๋านะคะเปิด
พี่สาวมีเงินไหม
ในกระเป๋าครูเอ๋เอ๋มีเงินมี
มีเงินเท่าไหร่คะ
มีเงินไทย 20 บาทก็
เห็นอยากเห็นแล้วแบบค่ะครูเอ๋
เอ้ยไปอยู่ตรงนั้นจะเห็นอย่างใช่ค่ะแค่
นั้นกองเป็นเห็นมีงาน 20 บาท 20 บาทอ๋อ
เงินไทยเงินประเทศไทยใช่เงินไทยพูดว่าบาท
ค่ะตอนนี้คุยอยากรู้ก่อนครูหญิงรู้อะไรคะ
เดี๋ยวครูเอกจะให้นักเรียนดูเงินไทยแตก
เงินไทยไหนบอกว่าเงินบาท
เงินอเมริกาผู้หญิงเงินก็อาจไหมคะเงิน
อเมริกาไม่ใช่เงินบาทค่ะเป็นเงินอะไรคะ
เป็นเงินดอลลาร์ฮอดเงินดอลลาร์นี่ละเขียน
ยังไง
แล้วเงินคุณทาดาชิเงินญี่ปุ่นเป็นเงิน
อะไรคะก็คุณธนาชิบอกว่าอะไรคะครูเอ๋คนไทย
แล้วที่บอกว่าเป็นเงินเงินคุยมีด้วยนะโอ้
โอ้
นี่งู
1000  0 ครูเอ๋มี 1,000 บาทมี 1,000 บาท
อะไรคะ
1,000 เยนเอา
อย่างนี้ไหมคะผู้เอกผู้หญิงเคยเห็นใช่ๆ
ตัวเองมีน 1000D นุมากไหมยกเยอะไหมคะครู
เอ๋ 1,000 เยน
1,000 เข้ากับเดี๋ยวนะผู้หญิงเท่ากับกี่
บาท
1 กฤษณ์ 100 บาท
100 บาท
300 บาท
ประมาณ
300 บาทค่ะหนูก็เยอะนะคะครูเอ๋ก็คุยเอม
มีเงินเยอะนี่ไม่ใช่ 20 บาทตัวเองให้สัก
1,000 เยนเอาะเงินประเทศญี่ปุ่นพูดว่า
เย็นชาย
ทิ้ง
คุณลิซ่าคนไต้หวันใช่มั้ยอ่าาถ้าไม่ใช่
ค่ะคุณลิซ่าเงินไต้หวันพูดว่าอะไร
เย็นบาทดอลลาร์
เงินไต้หวันดอลลาร์ค่ะดอลล่าเหรอคะ
ดอลลาร์ไต้หวันขอ
[เพลง]
นี้ศาลก็มีเงินไต้หวันดอลลาร์เงิน
US  Dollar เงินเย็นเออ
คุณ
คุณคุณอะไรครูเอ๋
คุณเกาหลีคุณแตฮีคุณแพเงินเกาหลีพูดว่า
อะไรคะงั้นเป็นบาทไหมไม่ใช่เงินบาทเอาไม่
ใช่หรอ
คุณ jacky บอกเงินวอน
เงินเกาหลีเป็นเงิน
วอน
W ล่ะเงินวอนเงินวอนมีใครอีกคะ
คุณโรเบิร์ตแพททินสันมาจากฤทธิ์อังกฤษ
ลอนดอนๆค่ะเงินลันฎอนเงินอะไรคะเงินบาท
เงินเย็นแต่ไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่เงินอะไร
เงินปอนด์เตอลิง
โอ้ผู้หญิงเก่งมากเขียนใช่ไหมว่า 1-2
แล้ว
แต่คนไทยพูดปอนด์ 5 ปอนด์ a  check ให้
ไหมเงินได้ค่ะตัวเองเงินปอนด์ ๘ คนอังกฤษ
พูดข่าวคนไทยพูดปอนด์ของานปอนด์
จ่ายล่ะครูเอ๋เช็คกว่าครูหญิงเขียนถูกไหม
ครูเอ๋ไม่รู้
ผู้หญิง
มีอะไรคะ
1 ขีดก็มีสองขีดก็มี
2-1 โอเค
เล่นเกมแบบนี้เนาะผู้หญิงใส่คล้ายๆกันล่ะ
1 ขีดค่ะ 1 ขีดเงินปอนด์น้องเงินประเทศ
อังกฤษเนี่ยเรียกว่าเงินปอนด์น้อก็มีเงิน
US  Dollar
เงินเย็น 20 ญี่ปุ่นเงินวอนประเทศเกาหลี
เงินปอนด์อังกฤษชนะประเทศอังกฤษเดี๋ยวกู
เองเงินอีกหนึ่งครั้งนะคะอ่าประเทศ
อเมริกาเงินอะไรนะคะเงินดอลลาร์ประเทศ
ญี่ปุ่น
เงินเย็นประเทศไทยไต้หวัน
ดอลลาร์ไต้หวัน
ประเทศเกาหลี
มีเงินวอน
ประเทศอังกฤษ
เงินตอนประเทศอินเดียคุณประวีณา
ก็คุณปวีณาบอกว่าอินเดียเงินรู้ปีเงิน
รูปีโรปี
รูปี้เขียนแบบนี้แต่ไม่รู้ไม่ใช่ไง
กู a หาให้เงินลุงพี่นะคะอ่ากอล์ฟประเทศ
ไทยเงินบาทเงินบาท
หรือ 2 ขีด
กูเองยังไงคะครูเอ๋เงินรูบิโอ้โห
ผู้หญิงเขียนได้ไหม
นี่หรอ
ใช่ไหมคะใช่เนอะเออทรายอ่ะแนะนำสั้นๆ
หน่อย
โรปีประเทศอินเดีย
เงินโรปีนะคะ
ก็รู้จักเงินประเทศนักเรียนแล้วเนาะ
คูเอกมีมีประเทศอะไรอีกครบหรือยังยังไม่
ครบครูเอ๋เอ๋มีสวะเทศชายคุณ John สวีเดน 5
คุณ John สวีเดนเงินอะไรนะคะเงินสวีเดน
อ๋อคุณจอนบอกว่าว่าเงินสวีเดนเงินโครนาโร
น่าใช่มั้ยโครนโครน่าสวีเดน
แล้วเงินเงินครูหน้าเขียนยังไงเขียนยังไง
ครูเอ๋
เอ๋เอ๋หา
ครูเอ๋แต่กำลังหาพี่
เบอร์โทรศัพท์ว่าเองเงินโครน่า
เขียนยังไงเมื่อนี้เป็นเงินดอลลาร์เงิน
เยนเงินวอนเงินปอนด์เงินรูปีเงินบาทนะคู๋
หา Google ไม่บอก
คุณ
สกุลเจาะขอจรกำลังคิดเหมือนกันเธอคุณชร
โอ้ไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรครูเอ๋โอเคถ้าครู
เอ๋เอ๋หาไม่เจอที่ Google  OK  OK
แจกครูเอรู้อยากรู้อยากรู้เขียนยังไงไม่
เป็นไร
ไม่เป็นไรชายค่ะไม่เป็นต่อไปอย่าเชื่อ
เพราะคุณจอห์นก็ลืม
1  2  3  4  5  6  7  8 หน้า
คุณแคะคุณแคทประจับประเทศอะไรนะคะครูเอ๋
อเมริกาค่ะอเมริกาก็
ดอลลาร์ไทยค่ะอาบเค้กรู้จักเงินนักเรียน
แล้ววันนี้ให้นักเรียนดูเงินไทยชายว่านัก
เรียนมาประเทศไทย
ใช้เงินไทยชายเงินไทยก็จะมีเงินแบงค์ค่ะ
งั้นแบงค์แล้วก็เหรียญค่ะเรียนกลมกลมกลม
กลมๆผู้หญิงในคูเอาคอมพิวเตอร์ใหม่ใกล้ๆ
นะคะอ่ะสุดท้ายค่ะนักเรียนจะได้เห็นเงิน
ไทยพัฒน์ชัดนะคะใส่ค่ะ
เอาเหรียญก่อนนะคะครูหญิง
เงินไทยมีเหรียญอะไรบ้างคะครูเอ๋อันนี้
เหรียญเล็กๆเห็นเห็นงานเห็นเห็นตรงๆเฉยๆ
เล็กๆ
โอเคเห็นแล้วค่ะเห็นแล้วเห็นแล้วโอเคโอเค
เห็นเห็น
1 บาทค่ะผู้หญิงวันนี้ 1 บาทเงินไทยเงิน
บาทนั้น 1 บาท 5 มีมีด้านนี้ที่กูหญิง
เห็นเนาะเป็นอุ้ย
เล็กมาก
อันนี้ใครคะอ๋อมีหัวใช่ไหมคะหัวในหลวง
และ
ในหลวงแล้วก็อันนี้เป็น
เห็นไหมคะเห็นค่ะคุณเองเป็นวัดค่ะ
วัดนักเรียนเห็นณวัดชายเป็นตาวัดขาว 1
บาทนะคะอ่ะกลับไปเรียนที่ 2  2 บาทค่ะ
เรียนนี้
2 บาทตู้แป๊บมีหัวเนาะค่ะแล้วก็ข้างหลัง
เอาอันนี้ไม่ใช่ไว้นะเป็นชื่อนะคะชื่ออัน
นี้ในหลวงที่ 10 ค่ะแล้วมีเหรียญอะไรอีก
คะครูเอ๋อันนี้เหรียญ
5 บาท
หนัง x
อาบอดข้าวนะคะหัวในหลวงค่ะอันนี้เรา
เรียกก้อยนะคะคุณก้อยหัวกับก้อยนะคะ
มีสองฝั่งหนึ่งชื่อนะคะเป็นผ้าบาทมี
เหรียญอีกเหรียญ
เหรียญเหรียญ 2 บาท
สองบาทเนี่ยสีทองค่ะสีทองเหรียญ 1 บาท
กับค่าบาทสีอะไรคะสีเงินท้อต่อไปสีสีทอง
แดง
เหรียญอะไรคะครูเอ๋
เหรียญ 5 เหรียญ 10 สตางค์
นี้
เนี่ย
50 สตางค์นะคะแล้วก็เรียนสุดท้ายอันนี้
50 สตางค์อันนี้เหรียญเล็กๆ
ที่สุดเหรียญอะไรคะ
เล็กมากๆนักเรียน
เล็กบอกว่ามึงเห็นไหมเห็นค่ะเห็นแล้วก็
อันนี้ใหญ่กว่า
ต่าง 25 สตางค์ค่ะ
นะจ๊ะ
25 สตางค์ 4 เหรียญ
เข้ากับ
1 บาท
[เพลง]
50 สตางค์
กี่เหรียญชะ 2 เหรียญหมอเข้ากับกี่บาทก็
เข้ากับ 1 บาทนี้
โอเคเหรียญสุดท้าย
เหรียญอะไรดูเอตเหรียญกี่บาท
เฮ้ยไอ้ซอง
เหรียญ 10 บาท
ของ 6 อันนี้ใหญ่ที่สุดเลยใช่ไหมคะใหญ่
ที่สุดค่ะใหญ่ที่สุด E สีเงินแล้วก็สีทอง
อันนี้หัวค่ะแล้วก็อุ้ย
ก้อยเป็นวัดนะคะวะ
10 อาสา
[เพลง]
เหรียญหมดแล้วขอมี 1  2  3  4  5  6 เงิน
เหรียญมี 6 เหรียญหรอคะเหรียญเหรียญค่ะ
แต่มีเงินแบงค์โห
เงินแบงค์
เงินแบงค์มีเท่าไหร่บ้างคะครูเอ๋เอ๋เงิน
แบงค์แบงค์ที่ 1 สีเขียว
สีเขียวกี่บาทคะแบงค์ที่ 1 คุยจากงง 20
บาทค่ะหน้า 20 บาท 20 บาทนะคะ
คะอะไรคะถามได้ไหมคนนี้ใครคนนี้ในหลวงที่
10 นี่ผู้หญิงวาดรูปในหลวง
ในหลวงที่ 15 ในหลวงที่ 10 ข้างหน้าข้าง
หลัง
ข้างหลังมี 2 พี่ฝนใช่ค่ะใครคะครูเอ๋อา
ในหลวงที่ 2 ในหลวงที่ 3
เห็นไหม
เงินเห็นเนาะเห็นเห็นนิดหน่อยนะคะค่ะเห็น
นี้ 20 บาทนะคะ
โอ้ผู้หญิงเห็นแม่คุณเห็นครูเอ๋นะจริงไหม
ผู้หญิงจังแบงค์ต่อไป
Bank ต่อไปค่ะผู้หญิง
สีอะไรคะครูเอ๋สีฟ้า
สีเหมือนอันนี้สีฟ้า
สีฟ้าแบงค์เท่าไหร่คะถ้า 50 บาท
แบงค์ 50 บาทค่ะอ่ะค่ะไม่น่าก็ในหลวงที่
10 แถวแล้วข้างหลัง
เหมือนแบงค์ 20 ไหมคะไม่เหมือนค่ะพบทำไม
แสงมากๆ
โอเคมั้ย
โอเคเดี๋ยวมันก็ต่างๆ
โอเคโอเค r  o  k
ในหลวงที่
แล้วก็ในหลวงที่ 4 ค่ะอ๋อ
งั้นแบงค์ 20 ก็ในหลวงที่ 1 กับ 2
ให้หลวงที่ 1 กับซ้อมนะครูเอ๋บอก 2 กับ 3
ใช่ไหมตอนแรก
คู๋ดูผิด
ขอโทษค่ะ
นักเรียนบอกไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรเข้าใจผิด
เลยนะฮะแบงค์ 20 ในหลวงที่ 1 ในหลวงที่ 2
ค่ะแบงค์ 50 ในหลวงที่ 3 ในหลวงที่ 4
อ่างล่าง
แล้วก็ต่อไป
Bank ต่อไปสีอะไรคะสีสีแดง
สีแดงเหมือนแก้วครูหญิงสีแดงสีแดงแบงค์
เท่าไหร่คะครูเอ๋แบงค์ 100 ค่ะกู
100 บาท
ฮะจอดข้างหน้าในหลวงที่ 10 ค่ะข้างหลัง
ข้างหลังในหลวงที่ 5
[ปรบมือ]
ในหลวงที่ 6 โง่อ่ะ
456 ในหลวงเองในหลวงที่ 6 นะคะ
แบงค์ต่อไป Bank ต่อไปสีอะไรคะครูเอ๋สีสี
ม่วง
โฮ 4 สีม่วงแบงค์สู้ไหร่คะ 5  500 บาท
งู 500 บาทค่ะ
ด้านหลังเป็น
ในหลวงที่เท่าไหร่คะในหลวงที่ในหลวงที่
เจ็บ
ในหลวงที่ 8 รู้
ถ้าร้อยบาทนะคะพี่มีอีกไหมคะครูเอ๋มีแค่
ครูเอ๋มีอีกหนึ่งแบงค์
สีอะไรคะสี
สีน้ำตาล
สีน้ำตาลแบงค์เท่าไหร่คะครูเอ๋
1,000 บาท
หูหนึ่งเหอะเยอะแยะ
ไม่เท่า 1,000 ใช่ไหมคะไม่เท่า 1,000 บาท
มากกว่าเนื้อ 1,000 บาทด้านหลังเป็น
ในหลวงที่เท่าไหร่คะ
ในหลวงที่
9 กับเท่ากับ 9 ย9ตะกุยในหลวงที่ 9 แล้ว
ก็ในหลวงที่ 10
หมดหรือยังคะครูเอ๋หมดแล้วนะคะอ่ะก็มี
แบงค์มีแบงค์ทั้งหมดนะคะผู้หญิงอีกแล้ง
20 บาทเอาสีอะไรคะสีเขียวค่ะ
50 บาทสีอะไรคะสีฟ้าค่ะ
100 บาทสีอะไรดูสีแดงค่ะ
Bank อะไรคะผู้หญิงแบงค์ 500 บาทค่ะ
แบงค์ 500 บาทสีอะไรคะสีม่วงค่ะสีม่วงนะ
คะแล้วก็แบงค์อะไรคะคุยอิงแป๊ง 1,000 บาท
ค่ะ 1,000 บาทสีอะไรคะ 1,000 บาทสีน้ำตาล
ค่ะมีน้ำตาลโอเคเอกก็มี 1,000 บาท
กี่บาทนะ 500 บาท
กี่บาทคะ
100 บาทค่ะกี่บาทคะ
50 บาทค่ะกี่บาทร้าน
20 บาทค่ะสิบบาทอันนี้เป็นแบงค์ราคาห้อง
นี้แบงค์ 1
2  3  4  5
1  5  455 แบงค์ปีห้าแบงค์แล้วก็มี
เหรียญนี้เหรียญอะไรบ้าง
มีเหรียญ
25 สตางค์ดังเด็กหรอแล้วก็ 50 สตางค์ค่ะ
ใหญ่นิดหน่อยใจแล้วเหรียญอะไรอีกคะ
1 บาทค่ะค่ะ
เหรียญอะไรอีกคะ 2 บาทค่ะ
เหรียญอะไรอีกคะแค่บาทค่ะงูแล้วก็เรียน
อะไรคะ 10 บาทค่ะ
พูดหรือยังทั้ง
หมดแล้วมีเหรียญทั้งหมด
2  3
4  5  6
ข้อ 6 เหรียญ 6 มีแบงค์ห้าใบนายนะคะตลาด
นักเรียนมาเมืองไทยก็เข้าใจเนาะเวลานัก
เรียนเรียก Taxi
[เพลง]
Taxi  Taxi ขาพืช
เดี๋ยวเสียงหาเบรคค่ะ
ไป
เซ็นทรัลเวิลด์อ่ะโอเคแล้วคุยกับพี่
เซ็นทรัลเวิร์ลจะสุขุมวิทเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์
แท็กซี่ก็
กดมิเตอร์ค่ะอ่ะ
จะถึงเซ็นทรัลเวิลด์ปีบาทคะมิเตอร์
แท็กซี่บ่ก็ 100 บาทก็
100 บาทเวลาจ่ายเงินใช่ไหมไม่ใช่อันนี้
1,000 บาทไม่ใช่หรือไม่ใช่อันนี้นะไม่
ใช่แบงค์นี้ค่ะแบงค์นี้ 1,000 บาทไม่ใช่
100 บาทไม่ใช่ไหมไม่ใช่สีม่วงไม่ใช่ 100
บาท Ok ใช่ไหมไม่ใช่อ๋อโอเคใช่ไหมคะใช่
ค่ะ
100 บาทหา
ถ้ามีสี
นะเก๋หาจ่ายค่ะคู๋ให้หาก่อนมีไหม
จะมีไหมผู้หญิง
กูเอ๋ไหมมี
แต่ว่า
VIVA มีแล้วก็ไม่มีรูเองขาอะไรครูเอ๋เอ๋
คิดมีแท่นมี 50 บาท
1  2 ได้ค่ะถ้าครูเอ๋มี 50 บาท 1 ใบ
50 บาท 2 ใบก็เท่ากับ
100 บาท 1 ไบต์
และกูอีกมี
20 บาทให้แท็กซี่ได้ไหมได้ 20 บาท 5 ใบ
เท่ากับ 1  2
3  4  5  5 ใบเท่ากับ
100 บาท
อือโอเคนะคะ
เรามีมีเวลาไหมคะโอ้เราหมดเวลาแล้วค่ะครู
เอ๋เฮเราหมดเวลาแล้ววันนี้นะเรียนรู้จัก
เงินไทยเงิน
เหรียญงาแบงค์ๆนักเรียนไปซื้อของ
โอเคให้แท็กซี่
โอเคครูเองกับผู้หญิงจะไป
ซื้ออาหาร
มีเงินแล้วใส่ค่ะวันนี้ครูเอกไม่ใช่กูเอง
ที่กูหญิงค่ะครูยิ้มกับครูเอ๋ก็ทำอะไรคะ
อ่ะมือยึดงานแล้วครับเก็บนะคะค่ะมี
กระเป๋าเก็บเก็บใส่กระเป๋า
[เพลง]
แล้วก็คู๋ต้องมีมีอะไรครับครูเอ๋
แอลกอฮอล์ล้างมือ
ร้อน
ทำไมแอลกอฮอล์ล้างมือมั้ยราซขอเงินติ
ไวรัส
ล้างมือล้างโอเคบ๊ายบายบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะ
สวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ